what time do you wake up at 4:30 5 oh
cuz Mark wallberg wakes up at 2: do you
get up at 2:30 when you're training I do
yeah I can't call on Mark cuz
we did a movie together and Mark was up
early but he he did get sleepy around
300 p.m. bedtime 7:30 6:30 7:30
depending on what time I have to wake up
I have to get 8 hours you and you can't
go to sleep at that hour cuz you're
tired by I'm done around 300 p.m. he
disappears so that nap time could be bro
I've read that like 24-hour breakdown of
his day it's crazy Mark Mark is a very
uh committed systematic guy I wake up
say my prayer do a little bit of reading
then I go for breakfast then I go to the
gym then I eat again I'm already like 4
and a half meals in already today Mark
that schedule doesn't exist for this
24-hour period I mean that's but this is
what I mean how literal the world takes
the Jesus Christ he's only spend 16
minutes with his kids